c'est l'heure du journal de l'afrique
soyez les bienvenus sur france 24 à la
une ce soir la dépouille d'un héros
national de retour sur sa terre la dent
de patrice lumumba seuls restes du corps
de l'ancien premier ministre assassiné
est arrivé aujourd'hui en république
démocratique du congo la dépouille doit
effectuer une tournée à travers tout le
pays avant d'être inhumé à kinshasa le
30 juin jour de la fête de
l'indépendance les détails dans un
instant
ce soir nous recevons patrick moya
ministre congolais de la communication
nous aborderons a décrit la question
sécuritaire dans l'est du pays mais
aussi les relations que la république
démocratique du congo entretien avec le
rwanda interview à suivre dans ce
journal enfin panne sèche à conakry les
stations service n'ont plus de carburant
une pénurie qui frappe la capitale
guinéenne depuis deux jours quel stade
quelques stations sont restées ouvertes
pour vendre leurs stocks de longues
files d'attentes ont bloqué certains
axes doucement à conakry dans ce journal
la dent de patrice lumumba est arrivée
en république démocratique du congo ce
mercredi 61 ans après l'assassinât du
héros national un retour très attendu
qui marque le début d'une tournée d'une
dizaine de jours à travers le pays avant
une cérémonie d'inhumation à kinshasa la
capitale le 30 juin ont fait le point
sur le programme avec notre
correspondant clément dona
l'avion qui a transporté depuis
bruxelles la dante du premier premier
ministre congolais est arrivé mercredi
matin pour une escale technique à
kinshasa le cercueil de patrice lumumba
et la délégation qui l'accompagné se
sont ensuite envolés pour la province du
sankuru dans le centre du pays c'est là
qu'est née patrice lumumba en 1925 dans
le village d'onna loire baptisé lumumba
ville en 2013 au programme deux jours
d'hommages coutumier et de recueillement
en famille le cortège mettra ensuite le
cap au nord direction kisangani l'ancien
fief politique de patrice lumumba puis
il se rendra dans le katanga dans le sud
du pays et plus précisément à xi'an
tembo là où l'ancien héros de
l'indépendance a été exécuté le 17
janvier 1961 enfin lundi 27 juin ce sera
le retour à kinshasa pour trois jours de
deuil national
la dépouille fera notre mon étape au
palais du peuple le siège du parlement
congolais ainsi qu'à la primature et
jeudi 30 juin le jour de la fête de
l'indépendance une grande cérémonie
d'inhumation aura lieu en mausolée a été
construit à cet effet sur la place de
l'échangeur de limete en plein coeur de
la capitale congolaise
les tensions de plus en plus vive entre
la république démocratique du congo et
le rwanda la situation sécuritaire dans
l'est du pays est la résurgence du m23
dans le nord kivu autant de questions
que nous aborderons avec notre invité
patrick moya ministre congolais de la
communication merci beaucoup d'être avec
nous sur ce plateau et d'avoir accepté
notre invitation
alors tout d'abord j'aimerais vous faire
réagir sur le retour de la danse patrice
lumumba en république démocratique c'est
un grand moment que nous avions attendu
depuis bien longtemps parce que patrice
eméry lumumba représente ceux qui dès le
départ des nos pays donc aux années de
l'indépendance qui ont fait le choix de
la liberté qui ont fait le choix du
combat pour l'affranchissement du peuple
congolais le combat pour l'intégrité
nationale vous parler de la situation à
l'est nous y reviendrons c'est une
séquence historique qui fait un peu la
prolongation du séjour du roi debels que
nous avons reçues en république
démocratique du congo s'il ya eu des
regrets profonds pour la colonisation
mais pour le combat il ya je crois un
travail de réconciliation qui a
véritablement commencé parce que vous
avez suivi des excuses la reconnaissance
pleine de la culpabilité des certains
déçus a été impliqué dans son ignoble
assassinat et donc nous pensons que
c'est si ouvre une nouvelle fenêtre dans
nos rapports notamment avec la belgique
mais pour nous en république
démocratique du congo pour sa famille
principalement ceux ci est un grand
moment qui nous permet à la fois de nous
réconcilier avec notre histoire de
retrouver un des maillons principaux
mais aussi de permettre à l'afrique et
le monde vénéré et de rendre hommage à
cet homme qui a donné beaucoup pour
l'afrique et en a reçu son petit neveu
sur ce plateau qui souhaite aussi que la
vérité soit faite sur les circonstances
de sa mort
alors on va aborder une autre question
avec vous une question d'actualité il
n'a échappé à personne que les relations
entre la république démocratique du
congo votre pays et le rwanda ne sont
pas bonnes
êtes vous au bord de la rupture le
rwanda est il aujourd'hui en guerre
contre la république démocratique du
congo vers ben oui s'ils choisissent de
soutenir un mouvement terroriste de
manière claire en plein jour ça veut
dire qu'ils ont fait le choix de la
guerre c'est vraiment dommage parce que
nous pensions que depuis l'arrivée du
président tu sais qu'il ya la tête de la
république démocratique du congo il y
avait une véritable fenêtre de paix et
qui s'est ouvert on a réchauffé les
relations diplomatiques au bout de trois
ans et nous avons mis en place des
mécanismes qui nous permettait à la fois
des discuter des questions économiques
des questions politiques et même des
questions sécuritaires qui à mon avis ne
devrait jamais aboutir ainsi à qu'on
arrive aujourd'hui mais c'est là
démontre clairement que dans l'agenda du
gouvernement rwandais la paix n'est pas
à l'ordre du jour fort malheureusement à
ce que le maintien de cette partie de la
république démocratique du congo dans
l'instabilité doit sûrement servir des
intérêts il ya des rapports des nations
unies qui ont démontré que cette partie
de la république démocratique du congo a
été particulièrement pied avec le
président tshisekedi nous avions fait le
choix de la paix où on pouvait discuter
y compris des intérêts économiques voir
comment les populations qui échangent au
quotidien massivement pouvez bénéficier
d'un certain nombre d'avantagés mais là
nous faisons des pas beaucoup des pas en
arrière parce qu'il ya justement des
desseins inavoués alors est-ce qu'il y
aura encore un autre pas en arrière est
ce que vous envisagez de rompre les
relations comme le souhaitent certains
responsables politiques comme martin
mais assiste à ces stades lorsque on
vous impose une guerre nous avons nous
la responsabilité des défendre notre
intégrité territoriale
mais en même temps c'est bien dommage
que cela arrive alors que nous venions à
peine d'adhérer à la communauté de
l'afrique de l'est où nous avions
discuté à la fois des questions
sécuritaires et économiques et tous les
chefs d'états d'état de la région ont
convenu qu'il fallait agir pour régler
les problèmes sécuritaires de manière
définitive en république démocratique du
congo les premiers pas en prévoyait un
volet politique vous avez vu que le
président tshisekedi a eu l'occasion
d'échanger avec tous les groupes armés
et puis avait un volet militaire qui
interviendrait dans l'hypothèse où il ya
des forces qui sont récalcitrants et
fort malheureusement pendant que les
discussions évolué dans ses volets le m
23 millions aux terroristes soutenus par
le rwanda est venu comme donner un coup
de semonce à ses processeurs est avait
des preuves de l'implication de
l'épreuve apparaissent comme nez sur les
visages nous espérons que dans le jours
qui viennent la mission des nations
unies au cours ou qui travaillent avec
nous dans un centre d'opérations
militaires parce que toutes les zones où
les opérations ce etienne sont ouverts
notamment par des drones qui permettent
de voir le mouvement vous avez vu deux
militaires rwandais qui ont été arrêtées
au pays démocratique du congo ils ont
été interrogés par le mécanisme de
vérification et ils ont dit clairement
qu'ils étaient dans une opération
spéciale et qui se sont perdues 25 km à
l'intérieur de notre pays et donc vous
voyez qu'il ya des preuves patentes que
nous brandirons progressivement mais
c'est bien dommage parce que nous étions
dans engagé dans un processus qui ne le
pensions pouvait nous permettra d'avoir
la paix et finalement permettre à nos
populations qui cohabitent au quotidien
d'aller un peu plus loin dans les
échanges économiques dans les échanges
culturels mais là c'est bien dommage
alors on va parler aussi d'un autre pays
voisin de l'ouganda mardi le président
de l'assemblée nationale christophe
baudot a dénoncé l'implication de
l'ouganda dans la prise de la ville
frontalière de bunagana par le m23 la
semaine dernière l'ouganda coopèrent
pourtant avec les forces armées
congolaises contre les adf un autre
groupe armé qui vient justement de
l'ouganda sur le sol congolais que dit
le gouvernement à ce sujet évidemment il
ya eu il ya eu des informations qui sont
venues du terrain qui a testé qui a eu
c'est comme cette forme de complicité
qui ont fait suite à une série de tweets
que nous avions vu du fils du président
même ou cv ni qui encensent et entre
temps le président kagame et pour nous
dans la position dans laquelle nous
sommes il ya des discussions qui se
tiennent notamment au niveau des
états-majors parce que jusqu'à preuve du
contraire nous continuons les opérations
pour éclaircir évidemment ce qui s'est
passé les moment venu nous tirerons les
conséquences mais ici il faut noter que
la république démocratique du congo
s'est montré disponible pour gérer les
menaces communes parce que vous savez
par exemple que les adf est une
importation de l'ouganda y tue plus en
république démocratique du congo en
ouganda autant pour les fdlr le
cauchemar que nous vivons depuis 25 ans
c'est parce que nous avions ouvert nos
frontières pour être solidaire
génocide et les fdlr nous passons des
années des années à les combattre
aujourd'hui le rwanda n'est pas en
mesure de vous dire combien sont-ils
combien sont armées et qu'elles aient la
capacité de nuisance madame de votre
mémoire de journaliste vous ne direz pas
un seul jour où les fdlr ont essayé
d'attaquer le rwanda mais itunes aux
populations quotidien nous avons estimé
que ces menace des vrais être gérée d'un
des cadres précis et pour voir dans
quelle mesure finalement on ramène la
paix dans cette partie du pays et on
parle d'économie et on pas un sujet des
plans alors il ya nos sujets que
j'aimerais aborder avec vous ce lundi
les chefs d'état de la communauté
d'afrique de l'est se sont mis d'accord
sur la mise en place imminente d'une
force régionale pour mettre fin au
conflit justement dans l'est de votre
pays de la république démocratique du
congo cette initiative fait polémique
dans votre pays la présidence congolaise
assure que le rwanda ne fera pas partie
mais le communiqué de la présidence
kényane qui ne précise pas que le rwanda
ne fera pas partie cette question at
elle réellement et étrangers madame
regardez vous voyez c'est un communiqué
qui sanctionnait les réunions qui se
sont tenues à huis clos pendant des
heures les langage diplomatique à ses
côtes il a ses langages et tous ne
pouvaient pas être dit dans ses
communiqués mais audelà de ce qui a été
dit dans ce communiqué il y avait un
plan opérationnel qui avait été
présentée par des chefs d'état major et
dans ces réunions qui se sont tenues
notamment à goma les officiers rwandais
n'y avait pas pris part et donc quoi
qu'il en soit aujourd'hui le rwanda pose
problème pour nous parce qu'il est
établi qui soutient un mouvement
terroriste
et on ne peut pas accepter parallèlement
à ce soutien au mouvement terroriste
d'avoir le trou en tête chez nous fort
malheureusement nous ne transigerons pas
sur cette question donc le rwanda
n'enverra pas de troupes en république
démocratique du congo mais est-ce qu'il
prendra part quand même assez assez je
crois que dans les mécanismes prévus par
les états-majors parce que quoi qu'il en
soit même si le rwanda ne prend pas ne
prendra pas part aux troupes mais au
moins il y aura un partage de
renseignements parce que les fdlr c'est
un problème on en est au délà de tout le
rwanda doit mettre en place des
structures pour accueillir ces
sanguinaires qui sont chez nous et être
dans un programme d'aidé mobilisation en
même temps le rwanda doit être en mesure
de nous livrer à tous ceux qui sont des
criminels sous sanctions internationales
du m23 qui l'héberge dans son territoire
depuis de longues années parce que c'est
décide stratégie à tout moment on
utilise tel tel pour ressusciter ses
mouvements et s'assurer que cette partie
de la république démocratique du congo
est toujours instable mais face à cela
il rencontrera la résistance de des
congolais qui sont très vigilants quand
nous avions parlé de le mouvement de but
de ce journal aucun centimètre carré de
notre territoire n'est sera cédée
d'aucune manière ils battront peu ça
sera le mot de la fin merci beaucoup à
patrick mouiller un ministre congolais
de la communication merci d'avoir
répondu à nos questions c'est moi qui
vous remercie on part en guinée à
présent où depuis deux jours plusieurs
stations service sont à sec conakry est
frappé par une pénurie de carburant
de longues files d'attentes se sont
formées dans les quelques stations qui
utilisent leurs réserves une situation
qui paralyse les transports en commun
dans la capitale guinéenne les
explications de notre correspondant à
conakry mali mme diakité
ici comme dans plusieurs autres stations
de service que nous avons sillonné ce
matin de longues files de camions mais
le bus et autres engins de transport en
commun s'étendant sur plusieurs dizaines
de mètres certains conducteurs sous un
soleil de plomb quand place depuis des
heures sans avoir même espoir d'avoir
une goutte de carburant depuis
la station avec mona lisa
non je ne sais plus je ne peux pas
travailler
il peut rien depuis noël se garde ainsi
voici le carburant nous ayons mal demain
donc aussi là bas quant à nous on ne
peut pas seulement nous aurons deux
depuis la prise du pouvoir par les
militaires l'état guinéen est désormais
le seul importateur de carburant dans le
pays un mécanisme qui avaient tous deux
été assurés par les compagnies privées
par le passé aujourd'hui selon le
directeur de la société nationale des
pétroles cette crise est due à la
lenteur du traitement des dossiers par
les banques c'est la première fois qu'il
est arrivé à le faire donc on a eu des
petits problèmes d'enregistrement avec
les institutions financières parce
qu'ils ne sont pas habitués à ce que
l'état importe mais dieu merci cela
leurs problèmes qu'on a aussi nous
n'avons pas des grands centres de
stockage généralement qui nous font
passer s'être paré et malheureusement
c'est le cas mais nous y travaillons
pour créer des centres de stockage pour
voter déjà dans la capitale guinéenne le
premier saut au ralenti et le prix du
transport en commun a presque triplé à
cause de cette crise au de carburant les
régulateurs de l'audiovisuel du sénégal
du bénin et de la côte d'ivoire ont
entamé une médiation pour le
rétablissement du signal de france 24 et
de rfi au mali les deux médias du groupe
france médias mende ont été suspendus
définitivement dans le pays depuis la
fin du mois d'avril une rencontre a eu
lieu ce mercredi à dakar entre les
médiateurs et la pdg de france mais
diamant de marie christine saragosse
écoutez la
malentendu il ya eu des crispations
détention la période n'était pas très
favorable non plus et quand on vit avec
un tel lien avec le entre rfi france 24
et le mali c'est un lien tellement
important tellement
ancestrale je bats le dialogue de
l'emporter donc mois ci à cette
possibilité d'ouverture que j'ai
ressenti très fortement et qui m'a été
confirmée pendant cette réunion où on a
parlé de tout je saisis aussi cette
chance c'est une chance pour nos médias
c'est une chance pour nos deux publico
malik auquel on est très attachés c'est
une chance pour la liberté d'informer on
en vient à cette affaire de corruption
en afrique du sud le cinquième et
dernier rapport de la commission d'
enquête du juge dando a été remis au
chef de l'état cyril ramaphosa cet
après-midi à pretoria les précisions de
notre correspondante caroline dumay
c'est un juge john doe muqui a rendu son
cinquième et dernier rapport au
président ramaphosa un rapport qui est
le résultat de plus de quatre ans et
demi de travail mais comme il l'a
précisé il aurait pu passer dix ans
tellement le dossier était complexe au
final plus de 5000 pages qui font état
de pillages de toutes les entreprises
d'état sud-africaine des entreprises de
transport aux entreprises de médias en
passant par les entreprises d'armement
plus de 15 milliards d'euros un manque à
gagner énorme pour l'état sud africain
le président ramaphosa a qualifié la
tâche du juge dando de phénoménal il
considère que ce rapport est désormais
un instrument pour lutter contre la
corruption et pour que plus jamais je
cite cet assaut contre la démocratie sud
africaine ne se répète
le rapport va être transmis au parlement
reste à savoir s'il y aura des
poursuites judiciaires on sait que les
frères gupta qui étaient les bras droit
de l'ancien président jacob zuma ont été
arrêtés à dubaï il y aura sans doute
d'autres arrestations cas pour la
société civile ce rapport est une preuve
accablante de la corruption du régime
précédent
alors que la crise alimentaire et la
menace de la famine plane sur le
continent les inquiétudes sont fortes et
les réponses de la communauté
internationale sont encore timides pour
en parler ce soir ousmane diagana vice
président de la banque mondiale bonsoir
merci d'avoir accepté notre invitation
alors tout d'abord j'aimerai avoir vos
projections sur les mois à venir la
sonnette d'alarmé a déjà été tirée
notamment pour certains pays comme le
niger ou l'ethiopie qui sont déjà
frappés de plein fouet par une crise
alimentaire en effet ces pays sont
frappés de plein fouet par la crise
alimentaire et qui qu'on vous le savez
est causée par des événements des durées
structurelles quelques le climat le
conflit le sous financement de
l'agriculture à cela s'ajoutait mais
n'importe quoi j'ai cru à la guerre
à nucléaire et ceux qui a introduit
entraîné je dirais une description d'un
haut niveau de la logistique est donc
aujourd'hui on constate à la fois une
pénurie qui à son tour a déclenché une
inflation galopante et en même temps
puisque les anglais qui sont l'un des
principaux facture pour la fois
l'augmentation de la production et la
productivité se faisant rares il est
possible que cette crise et puis ceux du
lait le nombre de personnes qui
additionnel qui peut
tomber dans la pauvreté à cause de cette
crise là et c est estimée à plus de 30
millions de personnes
alors justement vous parlez de tous ces
problèmes structurels qui surviennent
depuis la guerre en ukraine il y à des
solutions qui sont apporter des
solutions à court terme mais que faut-il
faire à long terme pour que l'afrique
pour que le continent que ses nombreux
pays d'afrique ne ne dépendent pas de
des importations nourriture c'est le cas
par exemple pour l'ukraine et la russie
40% du blé vient d'ukraine et de russie
qui est qui qui qui a qui n'est pas
arrivé justement en afrique 30 millions
de tonnes de nourriture sont restés
bloqués que faut-il faire à long terme
pour que l'afrique ne soit plus
dépendantes est vrai que il faut des
solutions à long terme et je dirais déjà
que les solutions de court terme sont
indispensables parce que cette crise l x
2,7 et des individus ont des pluies est
essentielle parce qu'il s'agit de nos
vies ne pas pouvoir accès à
l'alimentation signifie qu'on ne peut
pas tout simplement à vivre et d émail
frappe le portefeuille parce que les
tigres ont augmenté de manière
significative donc par rapport à ça la
banque mondiale a apporté des réponses
immédiates à travers des programmes de
filets sociaux ont des revenus
monétaires aux populations et également
des vivres à travers un achat à
d'éléments qui peuvent être mises à la
disposition de ces populations les plus
vulnérables les plus affectées mais a
les solutions à long terme sont encore
beaucoup plus importante parce que
l'afrique dispose de quantités de terres
et beau extrêmement importante
l'afrique dispose aussi de savoir dans
le semaines de
grève les coupures est aujourd'hui à la
faveur des technologies on peut faire ce
qu'on y en avait un chat contre donc
chaque pack donc aller plus rapidement
donc une réflexion pour aider les pays à
10 pour définir des stratégies de
développement agricole pertinentes et
viable soutenir par des ressources
financières extrêmement important à la
fois pour produire localement c'est que
les pays africains peuvent harkis
compris les anglais former les
agriculteurs mais en même temps essayer
de réorienter la production a décollé
vers ce que les africains consomme nous
paraît être une nécessité et c'est la
raison pour laquelle nous faisons deux
choses une restructuration de notre
portefeuille d'interventions dans ce
pays pour la courbe et une plus solides
programmes d'agriculture et programmes
d'alimentation et d émoi et une
mobilisation de ressources au ccif
créative ou des secteurs qui sont
démarqués la pouvoir contribuer à la
modernisation de l'agriculture et à 10
de l'énergie économiques et la formation
alors justement vous parlez des
financements des financements de la
banque mondiale en tout cas pour
soutenir ces investissements et pour
moderniser l'agriculture
mais qu'en est il de la communauté
internationale il a souvent des
promesses qui sont faites c'est le cas
par exemple la coop 26 pour aider les
pays qui sont le plus touchés par le
réchauffement climatique à supporter ce
régiment et faire une transition
énergétique cet argent n'est toujours
pas arrivé on a vu aussi que le pam le
programme alimentaire mondial a annoncé
il ya quelques jours qu'il allait
rationnés
la nourriture pour les réfugiés qu'il
n'y avait plus assez de dons comment
faire pour convaincre la communauté
internationale qu'il y a urgence
maintenant à court terme alors pour ce
qui concerne la banque mondiale je puis
dire que depuis le déclenchement de la
crise nous avons fait beaucoup de choses
d'abord nous avons augmenté nos appuis
budgétaires à priser pays pour leur
permettre justement de faire face à
des impacts budgétaires
qui sont
opposés par le fait qu'ils ont accordé
un certain nombre de subventions à des
secteurs et donc du coup entraînant si
vous le faites des fictions pour le
financement d'autres secteurs de
développement nous avons financé des
pour aider des projets de protection
sociale mais en même temps avant la
crise nous avons financiers nous avons
mobilisé et cesser de se sont en train
d'être des caissiers contre un programme
ou pour ceux des pays africains dans le
cadre de la grande muraille verser 5,2
milliards $ et une partie importante des
solutions sont en train d'être décaissé
était plus la crise nous avons mis à
côté comme montant de 30 milliards de
dollars
essentiellement financiers des
programmes nouveaux dans les secteurs de
la culture
enfin dans le cas de nos portraits
existants nous avons regardé tous les
projets qui nous paraissent pas être 15
urgent aujourd'hui ou qui ne répondent
pas directement aux effets de la crise
alimentaire nous sommes en train de
redéployer ses ressources pour financer
des programmes particuliers est nouveau
dans les secteurs de l'agriculture oui
nous avons fait des annonces ap les
occasions mais nous avons toujours tenu
nous promet sera
alors une dernière question qui est
importante vous parler de tous ces
financements on parle aussi de la guerre
en ukraine il ya d'autres conflits sur
le continent l'insécurité notamment dans
le sel a des conséquences sur les
populations des villageois qui fuient la
menace djihadiste qui abandonnent leurs
terres abandonnent leur bétail dont les
enfants ne sont plus scolarisés ça aussi
des conséquences sur l'agriculture quand
un agriculteur abandonne sa terre et se
retrouve réfugiées ou déplacées
est-ce que vous avez aussi
des projets pour aider à lutter contre
l'insécurité pour permettre à ces
personnes de retourner chez elle vous
avez parfaitement raison indécis c'est
sur ces phénomènes parce que il fait
partie des causes
d'aggravation de la crise alimentaire
dans le pays afrique et en particulier
dans les pays du sahel les personnes qui
qu'on appelle aujourd'hui des déplacés
internes dans plusieurs pays étaient
essentiellement des actrices ou des
élèves éleveurs donc le fait qu'ils
n'ont eux pas s'adonner à leurs
activités traditionnelles contribue
justement alimenter les et cultures
alimentaires nous apportons des réponses
directes pour ces populations mais
également comme je le disais quand tour
à nous
favorisons des financements qui
permettent aussi à aux populations qui
le cède à ses ondes d'opérer dans un
comté de plus sécurisée et en même temps
de financier des activités de façon à
restaurer ces terres ont été dégradés
tout s'est si bien sûr un peu nous
savons que le conflit sont nés à la fois
des problèmes de gouvernance mais des
programmes de problèmes d'eau des
changements climatiques donc au focus
particulier sur des programmes
d'adaptation au changement climatique
avec pour objectif d'atténuer les
risques des déplacements massifs de
population et or sont au centre de nos
interventions aujourd'hui merci beaucoup
haussmann diagana vice président de la
banque mondiale merci d'avoir répondu à
nos questions merci beaucoup c'est la
fin du journal de l'afrique reste avec
nous dans quelques instants la suite de
paris direct avec claire bonnichon
[Musique]